y actualmente uno de los principales
retos a los que nos enfrentamos la
humanidad es el reto de la inmigración
es un reto que ocupa conversaciones de
mesa ocupada los grandes titulares de
los medios y también define quién ganó
quién pierde en una campaña política en
estos momentos parece ser que en épocas
anteriores de la historia de la
humanidad esto no era así los flujos de
población entre unas regiones globales y
otras representaban una oportunidad más
que un problema más que era una
oportunidad para adquirir nuevos
conocimientos para conocer nuevas
culturas nuevas sociedades
y para intercambiar nuevos productos era
una forma cómo la humanidad evolucionaba
a nivel político social y económico pero
ahora sucede lo contrario ahora esto es
un problema
el problema básicamente consiste en que
el modelo económico y el modelo político
en el que tanto habíamos confiado
se ha deshecho o se ha hecho trizas
porque grandes sectores de la población
y cientos de millones de personas están
quedando por fuera de este modelo
como consecuencia a través que es una
gran capa de la población de la
humanidad
ha perdido sus derechos económicos
derechos políticos ambientales laborales
sociales de todo tipo
y no estamos haciendo nada significativo
para resolver esta situación estas
personas en una medida desesperada
tienen que movilizarse tienen que
emigrar hacia regiones del mundo en
donde pueden encontrar unas mínimas
mejoras de sus condiciones de vida y de
alguna manera llegan a europa pero
llegan específicamente a las ciudades de
europa quiero decir con esto que las
ciudades de europa por las ciudades en
general se convierten en las
protagonistas y sobre ella recae la
principal responsabilidad es sobre cómo
recibir y acoger a estos nuevos sectores
de población
los estados los gobiernos nacionales
crean unos marcos políticos generales
sobre cómo enfrentar la problemática
pero son las ciudades quiénes tienen que
inventarse planes y estrategias
concretas herramientas específicas sobre
cómo acoger a estos nuevos sectores de
población y a los ciudadanos y a las
ciudadanas nos corresponde reflexionar
generar nuevos valores acerca de cómo
compartir cómo convivir con estos nuevos
vecinos y estos nuevos habitantes de la
ciudad
cuando hablo de acoger me refiero a
incluir a este sector de la población
dentro del tejido social y económico de
la ciudad pero este esto es bastante más
complicado de lo que parece
especialmente porque tenemos que buscar
los elementos comunes que tenemos
que nos permitan establecer lazos de
comunicación que nos permita tender
puentes entre tanta diversidad de
culturas y entre tanta diversidad de
idiomas
hace unos tres años un equipo de
personas
nos hemos reunido a pensar a reflexionar
en torno a esta cuestión que tenemos en
común que nos pueda comunicar y nos
pueda unir pues una de las mejores
respuestas que hemos encontrado es la
gastronomía la gastronomía entendida no
como un plato de comida servido en una
mesa sino todo lo que le rodea y todo lo
que está detrás del plato es decir las
relaciones sociales la cultura la
familia los recuerdos la amistad las
celebraciones el conocimiento las formas
en que se transmiten los conocimientos
nos parecía que la gastronomía era una
manifestación de la grandeza del
espíritu humano en el sentido de que
hemos logrado transformar
un acto o una necesidad tan biológica
como alimentarse en algo tan poderoso y
con tanta carga simbólica como es la
gastronomía
nos parecía que nos llamaba mucho la
atención que a los seres humanos nos
gusta cocinar para los demás
generalmente también generalmente nos
gusta sentarnos a compartir comida con
otras personas
esto nos llevaba a la deducción de que
la gastronomía era tal vez uno de los
actos más generosos que teníamos los
seres humanos a partir de esta idea
empezamos a recorrer la ciudad a
preguntarnos a investigar cuáles son los
espacios que utilizan las diferentes
comunidades de inmigrantes para
compartir la comida
por supuesto lo primero que encontramos
es un
una serie de restaurantes de diferentes
orígenes de diferentes naciones google
nos hizo la no resolvió el problema en
dos segundos pero no era eso lo que
estábamos buscando es para encontrar esa
dimensión cultural y esa dimensión
social en google no estaba entonces
tomamos la decisión de caminar la ciudad
de preguntar el voz a voz nos llevaba de
un sitio a otro al final encontramos
además de una exuberante lista de
restaurantes y de tiendas de alimentos
personas inmigrantes encontramos formas
de organización de mujeres especialmente
de mujeres en torno al cultivo en torno
a la cocina en torno a la celebración
que en las que grupos de mujeres se
organizaban y se formaban asumían la
gastronomía como una forma de
empoderamiento
quizá lo más interesante en esta parte
ha sido que hemos visto que esta era una
red oculta la ciudad que espero como un
organismo vivo una forma viva de cultura
que estaba invisibilizada para el resto
de la ciudad me refiero cuando digo
culto no me refiero a que estaba en un
barrio apartado o en una calle escondida
sino que podría estar en el centro de la
ciudad o podía extraer incluso dentro de
las rutas gastronómicas
el epicentro gastronómico de la ciudad o
incluso podían ser nuestros propios
vecinos y aún así no lo veíamos
y algo que nos llamó la atención que fue
lo que desató la chispa ha sido que
estas redes o estos mapas ocultos de la
ciudad están muy vivos a pesar de que
están ciertamente al margen tienen una
vitalidad cultural impresionante y en
ese momento dijimos que valía la pena
hacerlos visibles no solamente por el
bien de estas comunidades sino por el
bien de nosotros los que vivimos en la
ciudad y los que compartimos la ciudad
con ellos como una forma de visibilizar
esa enorme diversidad y ese potencial
cultural que había allí
empezamos a preguntarle a las personas
entrevistarnos con cocineros con
cocineras especialmente con las líderes
de estas organizaciones y empezamos a
encontrar unas historias de vida muy
interesantes historias de inmigración
pero sobre todo historias de lucha de
gente que con su trabajo lo único que
esperan es contribuir a mejorar a
construir una ciudad más digna a
construir una ciudad más humana
a partir de allí empezamos a hacer
actividades con ellos directamente
hacíamos talleres participativos
hacíamos actividades de reflexión por
supuesto todo alrededor de la comida
mezcla vamos comidas nos poníamos a
pensar a hablar alrededor de la comida
esto no nos parecía que era una manera
de generar reflexión en torno a la
diversidad todo esto lo plasmamos en
este proyecto que es un proyecto
editorial que recoge todo este proceso
como una forma de darle visibilidad esa
riqueza cultural que tiene la ciudad que
es una cuando teníamos la idea que
cuanta más diversidad cultural más
elementos de unión hay entre las
diferentes comunidades que conviven en
un espacio
y esto nos parecía importantísimo sobre
todo si pensamos en la ciudad que
tenemos ahora que es una ciudad que
generalmente tiende a separarnos los
ritmos de trabajo tan competitivos nos
dejan cada día menos tiempo para
socializar o las redes sociales la
tecnología básicamente nos deja nos
aísla cada vez más nos hace más
individualistas
y el modelo de ciudad especulativa nos
está arrojando de los barrios y nos está
sacando hacia sectores más apartados de
la ciudad de manera que la gastronomía
para nosotros nos empezamos a verla como
una forma de resistencia social de
resistencia cultural frente a esa ciudad
que nos quiere separar y nos quiere
individualizar
a donde quiero llegar con todo
con todo este esta historia que estoy
contando quiero plantear que en valencia
que sus ciudadanos y ciudadanas
estamos frente a una disyuntiva o
convertimos la inmigración en una en un
problema
podemos convertirlo en una oportunidad
privilegiada para convertir los barrios
para convertir nuestras comunidades y
nuestra ciudad en general en unas
ciudades en una sociedad más más
creativa más dignificada más que valore
más la diversidad cultural
un punto muy interesante que
encontrábamos aquí es que la diversidad
cultural es la base de la creatividad
porque cuantas más puntos de vista
diferentes hay en un espacio
mayor capacidad desarrollamos para
replantear nuestras propias ideas y para
generar unas nuevas entonces vemos de
esa manera conectado la diversidad
cultural con la creatividad y con la
capacidad de innovación de un territorio
de un espacio de nosotros mismos y esto
es especialmente importante porque es
que las nuevas ideas son los que van a
conducirnos hacia un modelo más
sostenible hacia una ciudad más
sostenible para todos y para todas con
el medio ambiente y con nosotros mismos
esto dependerá de
poder lograr un cambio de visión a nivel
de las instituciones y de nosotros y
nosotras como ciudadanos y ciudadanas
este cambio de visión la base creo que
es plantear los los que los inmigrantes
en lugar de ser sujetos pasivos simples
receptores de ayudas públicas
por el contrario sean se conviertan en
los sujetos activos con sus
potencialidades con sus con su cultura y
con su trabajo contribuyan a hacer una
ciudad más rica más rica en el pleno
sentido de la palabra
en el sentido no solo gastronómico sino
rico en el sentido económico y rico en
el sentido social y cultural
y quería lanzar una pregunta abierta que
es sobre si alguna vez os habéis
planteado visitar algún restaurante de
una gastronomía diferente a la propia
lanzó esta pregunta pero a la vez quiero
que que penséis o que reflexiones acerca
de que si tener esta experiencia
requiere una nueva visión una visión en
la que nos informemos un poco más
básicamente que tratemos de investigar
un poco sobre el contexto social
económico histórico de ese tipo de
gastronomía
qué pasa en sus regiones de dónde
procede que cuál es la diferencia entre
esta gastronomía y otra que quitemos esa
pátina exótica que hacen mucho daño que
homogeniza la diversidad cultural y
sobre todo que pensemos que detrás de
cada plato de comida de estas
comunidades hay una historia de lucha y
una historia personal hay una historia
de vida muy interesante hay hay personas
detrás de la comida
estos peque este pequeño cambio de
visión es un pequeño cambio personal
pero creo que puede ser la base de una
gran transformación social a muy largo
plazo pero pero de una magnitud mucho
mayor cuando sientes que cuando vas a un
restaurante de una comunidad de
inmigrantes está siendo una forma está
desierta de manera apoyando
económicamente
a una economía familiar un pequeño
negocio
pero también estás dando un
reconocimiento a su cultura y a su
trabajo y cuando cuando sabes que las
demás personas estas están interesadas
en tu cultura y que tú no eres solamente
un objeto exótico en ese momento te
sientes que hace parte de un grupo y que
además hace es parte de la construcción
de una ciudad de una sociedad y en ese
momento es cuando te sientes realmente
incluido en tu sociedad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]